Adam Schefter from the mothership the
Peripatetic reporter always busy and
busy this weekend with Jay Cutler back
in the NFL what was planned is it C I
guess after Cutler went Annie home went
down was it Plan B well you know there's
been a lot of discussion about the
options beyond Jay Cutler but I think
the truth of matter is is that they were
so focused on getting Jay color that
they never got to option BCDE F whatever
option you want to go to I think the
name Brock Osweiler came up in that
building and I was told last week that
Cleveland really was not interested in
parting ways with him I was told the
name teddy bridgewater came up and I was
told Minnesota would never part with him
he's the golden child there I was told
the name Blake gabart came up but Blaine
Gabbert but again in Arizona he looked
very strong in his preseason debut but
they never got to where they had to
consider strongly any other option
whether it was Brock Osweiler or Tim
Tebow or Johnny Manziel oh you bring up
the name it doesn't matter who they were
focused on getting Jay Cutler and they
got their guy in the end why are they
bringing in Cutler for one year and give
me best case worst case scenario of how
do you think this can play out well it's
one year on a one-year contract and
listen I think initially the first
thought was roll the two sides could
talk about a three-year deal but the
truth of the matter Dan is that it
really didn't matter on a three-year
deal because it was going to be
constructed as a one-year deal with an
option bonus if they went beyond one
year that the team would have the right
to pick up or not pick up so if Jay
Cutler goes in and plays well this year
the Dolphins then picked it up he makes
money if he doesn't play well they're
gonna release him anyway so basically he
was going to be on a one-year deal which
is why the two sides decided to
construct a one-year deal because if he
plays well they are not financially
obligated to Ryan Tannehill beyond this
year so now they're going to pay him
seventeen million this year but they're
out from under him financially if Jay
Cutler works out next year if not
then obviously they could turn back to
Ryan ten l depending on how he's
recovering from his knee injury and so
color best-case scenario goes into Miami
thrives under Adam geisha system as he
has in the past and they decide to
resign him and bring him back as Miami's
quarterback of the future worst case
doesn't play well injured struggles you
come up with it and basically it's a
one-year deal they're one and done and
they go on to the other options whether
that's Ryan Tannehill or somebody else
yeah I guess the concern I had is I
think Matt Moore is just as good as
Cutler is and you're bringing in Cutler
and the danger is believe it or not if
he plays well yes you get rid of
Tannehill but now I got a 35 year old
Jay Cutler in there and where's my
future you got to have a franchise
quarterback and you're sort of stuck in
that seven and nine to nine and seven
range and nobody wants to be in that
territory but Dan they were there anyway
with Ryan Tannehill and Matt Moore do we
know that Ryan Tannehill is a surefire
playoff bound we don't know that we know
so no so they're there anyway
they took basically the best case
scenario in the situation that they were
in with Ryan Tannehill having the knee
injury and I believe he's going to opt
for the knee surgery I believe he's
going to be out for the year and so
that's fine you think Matt Moore's
better maybe he is but the fact that
matters they were gonna need another
quarterback and Adam GaSe believes in
Jay Cutler knows him you didn't on the
big question what's Fox gonna do without
Jay Cutler now I said Tannehill deserves
that job or Kaepernick if Kollek a
practice shot in the butcher finally get
a job that's what he needs he finally
gets a job and I know people are trying
to make this into a Colin Kaepernick
story and I said this isn't Baltimore to
me is more of a Kaepernick story than
Miami because Miami's not the right
place and Adam GaSe is not the right
coach for him and certainly the Fidel
Castro t-shirt Miami Cuban based you
know that just that that was not going
to work out oh great and I think the
Baltimore case was very interesting
because I think I think the coaching
staff really
wanted him and I did there was a lot of
support for him and somewhere along the
way for whatever reason that was they
opted to go against him but that was
gaining momentum at one point it quickly
stopped and you're exactly right that
was an option Miami never really turned
into an option for Kaepernick and never
really evolved in that way and so here
we are it kind of drives me crazy I
guess it's the way the world Colin
capric now gets linked to everything
I'll go quarterback question it's just
unbelievable did Romo get any calls
who should I want time in did did Romo
get a call has he gotten any calls not
to my knowledge not yet and I think that
if you're Tony Romo Tony Romo is the
Dallas Cowboys break the glass murder
she planned if anything were to happen
Zach that's good that's that Tony Romo
plan to me other than that he's with
gymnast if dak Prescott got hurt in the
preseason mm-hmm finish then dead I
think they have to call Tony Romo
I mean to me that's the first call you
make when the Cowboys get in that room
the way the Dolphins got in that room
last year the room where it happens and
you're making the decision about which
quarterback to bring in and you're the
Dallas Cowboys in that spot are you
counting or believing in Kellen Moore to
save your season I don't think so are
you counting on another quarterback to
save his season I don't think so so to
me yeah that that's again Tony Romo was
to break the glass emergency for Dallas
if anything were to happen but Dec has
been great he's been durable and
hopefully that's not an issue for them
we're talking to Adam Schefter from the
mothership Tom Brady says it's basically
nobody's business about his concussions
Tom must be affected by these
concussions to say something stupid like
that how does the league react do they
react at all to what Brady had to say
since there is an injury report that you
have to was was he lying to the team did
the team know about it did they not put
him on the injured list and list it as a
concussion so is there any fallout to
this
you know I sure of them hiring Ted wells
again to investigate Brady I don't know
what they can do like they looked into
it he was not down on the injury report
as having sustained a concussion or head
injury people have gone through the
tapes and can't find it it's a very
difficult injury sometimes to identify
and players have done a great job of
concealing and I think that's been part
of the change in the culture surrounding
that injury King years ago people wore
concussions as a badge of honor and
strength
I got dinged that I'm going back in the
game ding ding and now that's not the
case now it's not great ever when a
player is concealing a concussion but I
think all of us can look at all the
comments that were made and agree that
we believe that at some point last year
at the very least Tom Brady suffered a
concussion
where when we don't know how it happened
don't know where's on injury report it
doesn't appear to be so you can't prove
it the league went back and looked at it
and didn't see anything
so it's one of those issues that to me
raises awareness but there's not
anything that could be done a couple
other things coming off the Hall of Fame
the fact that we saw Terrell Davis get
in so a briefer career but brilliant
during that brief career are the voters
kind of turn in the corner here or was
this just an aberration of looking at
Terrell Davis and a guy who gained 2,000
yards and they won Super Bowls here to
get into the Hall of Fame Dan I was
honored to be a voter for six years the
one thing that I learned is that there
are certain candidates that you can't
explain the game momentum in certain
years Terrell Davis I believe had been
on the ballot a couple of other times at
the very least and didn't get close what
happened in most two years that made him
all of famer that he wasn't those other
years why is it that a senior guy can
get in like any easy can get in all
these years later so all of a sudden in
2017 he's a Hall of Famer
but in 2007 he wasn't what changed so
what I've learned is that again certain
guys gain sir
in certain years and and it is a
political process and you should not be
fooled by it any other way
there are certain players that get
presented by certain voters who are more
persuasive and powerful than other
presenters and in many instances a
candidacy is bolstered by what the
present there is and the respect that
that guy has in that room and Terrell
Davis who I believe was presented by
Jeff Flake world of espn.com this year
who does a tremendous job did a great
job of pushing forth his candidacy and
gathering the pertinent information and
he got him in I don't think that because
Terrell Davis got in all of a sudden you
say oh now player X and I know they've
been solar examples I'm drawing a blank
on right now
who played only three years but thrives
should get into the Hall of Fame I mean
it's just not how it works
voters are not sitting around saying
well we let in Terrell Davis so let's
let in this other player who had a
shortened aborted career due to injuries
because it didn't work out it was not
out I don't think Terrell Davis's entry
into can influences the next guy in my
mind but can I look at Jimmy Johnson the
same way we look at Terrell Davis well
in a certain way you can what he coached
five seasons she won two Super Bowls
yeah and then left hand delivered a
third one for Barry Switzer but but but
I don't know if we I know we look at
longevity with coaches but can I is
Jimmie Johnson a Hall of Fame coach well
he is a Hall of Fame coach
I mean he's whether he's in there or not
he's a Hall of Fame type of coach in my
mind the question is whether the voters
are going to allow him to gain entry
into there and again I think you listen
to player has his coaching career or his
player like Terrell Davis has his career
cut off because of a physical injury
that he suffered not his choice Jimmie
Johnson made the choice not to coach
again and I know it doesn't sound like
much but there's a difference between a
coach was involved for five years and a
player who's involved for five years
it's just a subtle thing Jimmie Johnson
to me is one of the great coaches when I
was member when the one thing that
always stood out to me is they would say
you know this is the Hall of Fame can
you write the history of the game
without this particular individual and
in the case of Terrell Davis and you
could argue that he had an NFL MVP a
Super Bowl MVP a 2,000 yards season he
is taking part in a number of historical
events over time and to me Jimmie
Johnson's a part of NFL history as you
mentioned the two Super Bowls and teeing
it up for Barry Switzer and a third to
me he belongs in but I think it's a
different case looking at a coach and a
player
Adam NFL live at 1:30 Eastern every
weekday on the ESPN also he has a
podcast know them from Adam last week he
interviewed Hall of Famers Jerry Jones
and Terrell Davis
can we cap how long the speeches are
have they ever thought of just doing the
Academy Awards music there you know that
you you have to submit your speech let's
see how long it is and then they tell
you it has to you know we we got 20
minutes here there is so much that was
so wrong about what happened Saturday
night okay
the Gettysburg Address was delivered in
two minutes and 48 seconds I believe
you're telling me that you can't get a
Hall of Fame speech in and pay your
respects to the people that deserve it
in the course of oh say 20 minutes I
know Peter King this morning's best 22
minutes I was thinking on Saturday when
I discussed this issue with some people
20 minutes everybody gets 20 minutes and
then the lights go on and the curtain
comes down and that's it that's it it's
not fair to say Kurt Warner the seventh
candidate that night you to step up to
arena that's emptying out because people
are done we're not sitting these chairs
for five hours okay you know it's just
it's just not fair it's not right it
goes on and on I mean as a guy who has
written and then edited my own work for
27 years I'm listening to these speeches
and there was some great moving
incredible
just touching I got emotionally worked
up but there are other parts I this is
not necessary this is not necessary and
it just creates it to where it's to
there was one a hall of famer that I
spoke to on Saturday night who told me I
am never going to another one of these
ceremonies until they put a time limit
on these guys and cut it off at a
certain point how about 10 minutes and
then you get 5 minutes per Super Bowl
win after that well I like that Dan
that's that that works for me I mean I
spat through one Adam years ago when I
wasn't even working in the business and
I said I would never do that again
it was interminable and and I just said
you know make it tell these guys what's
good entertainment because they don't
know give me one great story thank a
couple of people and you know make it an
entertaining speech not something that
drags on and it loses its momentum and
it was just a deal it's the most
emotional moment of their life it's the
penultimate time of their careers they
get to pay tribute but it's just too
much let me tell you someone Steve
Young's father Britt
yeah presented him and spoke for roughly
30 minutes that ended the presenting
speeches as we know it they revised it
to where the presenters are now
interviewed and they cut up in difficult
films in an interview tape and they play
the presenter in a series of bytes over
the course of about 60 seconds and it
works great it's enough and in the case
of the people who are going into the
hall there's enough there something must
be done there to cut them off and
they've improved it all along the way
this is a ceremony that used to be done
in the middlee afternoon okay the Hall
of Famers on these plastic chairs you
get these big older men who are
miserably uncomfortable sitting in the
Canton Sun they moved it to the night I
noticed on Saturday night they have
these big leather chairs for the Hall of
Famers they're improving it and there
still are more improvements to be made
in terms of saying nobody is talking
beyond 20 minutes I don't care who you
are if Jesus came back to earth he
doesn't get more than 20 minutes that
night sorry I don't know JC is going to
get it
he had a great run man I gotta get in
twenty five ten twenty minutes okay
otherwise all the other whole families
can be turned off and like that one told
me he ain't going back even for JC you
know what they should say is for more on
my career go into the Hall of Fame where
my bio is or so like they could they
could do this in a tactful way all right
I have to go here you know about one of
the how about this you they scroll that
they can that the whole thing guy who
gets elected he gives a list of a
hundred people to thank to ESPN ten if
I'm going to scroll across the bottom of
speech no Terrell Davis would like to
thank Frank white Adam Schefter Dan
Patrick Neal's on and honor so all the
names are rolling and then give your
speech I like it
thank you Dan if I make the Hall of Fame
my scroll will have a shout out to you
and and and vice versa I am scrolling
down Africa the bottom my speech as well
thank you madam chapter NFL line Thank
You Adam the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience